hello and welcome to this video playing
I am printing panic what what are you
doing here really if I was playing what
and now he plays the trump and
international master really Hendrix bit
surprising him surprisingly the Trump
off scheme yeah yeah play the b5 the
funny funny line in a while since I look
at that looked looked at this so don't
quite remember how it works take care i
think now be fine do i do I have
something better you know before is fine
i think dark squares are extremely weak
yeah in the white side I don't know
clearly seven assists ambitious can also
just play Bishop d7 it looks interesting
why not dark squares has mentioned are
pretty weak if he goes Queenie to to
preserve yeah as Queen to deform it's
one interesting tribe and try to snatch
here
let's try I don't have to take I mean I
can also just go here and keep them from
castling 9f to maybe I wonder i would
like to rock the one who worked alone
94 would be great if i can get this end
somehow
let's see where he goes here to a 4 I
have Bishop d7 with the temple he would
always have some compensation yeah it's
pretty clear I'm not quite sure if it is
enough but see how it has some play now
I get 94 m that's one thing about this
Queen venture it's not just a pawn the
dark squares here are really weak that
you file an extremely annoying move your
phone now it's all kinds of stuff is
hanging c2 is hanging I can also play
Queen c3 which would oh clean screen g5
I should look at Queen g5 here oh my god
so something I have to look at f six
maybe yeah Queen g5 had two majors I had
to see I came if he goes 93 now I have
Quincy 3 this is good he wants to take
and click play Queen age 60 f for sure
if I grab this I'm ready to go with the
Queen back okay if necessary
Queen g6
we should be three year maybe and then
going to h6 yeah hmm i don't really have
a great move now
[Music]
which is where do I put this friggin
queen if I go to a to take H way I did
75 as a square
okay Queen age 67 what a wild position
really a wild pollution so takes maybe I
have to play the book back and like this
so that I have hope on the seventh
doesn't strike me as idea what I'm down
one time as well I don't know an engine
will probably hold this with these but i
don't i really don't know maybe you
maybe have something it's it's a little
bit it's murky
ya know Queen 87 is the thing I can do
this actually and and just put the look
here I mean that ending is greater I can
give up the exchange yet easily I have
so many so many phones on the queenside
and he have also threatening to kill him
on the G file so i don't think i don't
think yeah ok he plays I mean I don't
think he can objectively do that that
should be grateful black so jump through
the night down or just push and push the
pork I don't have much time
and it was taken on its recently
am i spoiling this this friggin position
that would be really annoying why was
completely done completely done I
actually just played simple stuff and
not this and now it gets gets extremely
weird now they've got 15 seconds that's
terrible why did I go see for I mean you
can just play the simple move anyway
anyway okay yeah this is the problem you
can now check me a million times okay
it's not even good Queen geforce better
[Music]
[Music]
any change made me with no tie where the
clock away though when an utmost stupid
game it it just did here nah come on
what do they like to win like half of my
winning position and then I would
probably be on 2600 rating and yep what
mine is just fishing young them so h 6
and this is getting dangerous and it was
clearly getting dangerous but
objectively speaking this position is
just bad anyway there were some
adventures and you cannot really play
perfectly here it was dangerous but i
mean i should simply win this position
why don't I just win the position I
don't get it just clean all the moves at
Queen g6 for example was something that
I saw and it's just easy no I have to
play complicated with c4 and allow of
this stuff here we should wear three
wins it's also an easy move don't
understand sometimes dan this is getting
days is getting dangerous simply
something that you cannot handle in 30
seconds but it's also completely
unnecessary because here you just have
to trade Queens and this is this is a
simple move you just trade Queens and
why this is why this just done because
of all those cons and you cannot move
here probably due to f5 or just take it
and this is also a simple simple thing
to play this is just now yeah be sugar 3
as well was really tough and lose this
game really tough can I manage their
queen g4 was winning the local change
and the way it happened i was totally
willing but i had like had no second
note i'm okay with four seconds you have
to pre move like crazy queen bee too
okay I didn't even see that tree to take
it was completely completely crazy yeah
you manage to make me with absolutely no
time when o'clock yeah okay it was was
crazy but it's just this is very simply
winning if you just be a little bit
cautious and not as c4 is just crap and
I took like 4 15 seconds for them or
just 15 seconds I can even just heck it
off yeah just take it off and win I mean
yeah i'd really like to keep this at
least 2,400 and keep losing stupid games
like this when you just get get the
point like here take it and I don't take
it okay anyway thanks for watching